bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7-8 société
ce soir on va parler des rythmes
scolaires alors dans les yvelines 240
communes sont concernées par le
changement de rythme scolaire 8
l'appliquent depuis la rentrée 2013 et
pour les autres et bien aujourd'hui ils
l ont jusqu'au 6 juin pour déposer leur
projet de réforme des rythmes scolaires
et une vingtaine de communes n'a à ce
jour toujours pas déposé de dossier
alors parmi ces communes qui font on va
dire ça comme ça de la résistance
il ya notamment votre commune la commune
de plaisir aux aussi fine couche onergie
bonsoir les deux expliqué dans quelques
instants pourquoi ça coince chez vous ça
coince aussi du côté des parents
florence aja comme bonsoir vous
représentez d'associations des gilet
jaune
et puis ça compte ça coince aussi du
côté syndical bertrand mesure bonsoir
expliquerait les raisons précises aussi
évidemment nous avions convié les
services de l'inspection académique
services qui n'étaient pas disponibles
pour venir débattre c'est ce que nous
regrettons et puis au même moment où
nous parlons ce soir en direct il y à
une manifestation de soutien au maire
ump de boer pas grégory gare et astier
qui souhaitent ce soir en conseil
municipal
faire voter une motion pour demander le
report d'un an de la mise en place de
cette réforme afin d'avoir des garanties
financières le maire de mortagne gary
astier estiment que cela coûterait 400
mille euros à la commune alors j'ai dit
le 6 juin c'est la fameuse date butoir
vous allez faire quoi
mais au cosmos bergé mais c'est le 6
juin le déposer votre dossier puisque
cinq des huit en tout cas on a prévenu
de l'inspection académique de notre
décision puisque la décision était
effectivement de demander un report mais
une suppression carrément et puis et
puis il ya deux poids deux mesures il
est clair qu'aujourd'hui on n'arrêtera
pas le combat si je peux employer ce
terme un peu guerrier mais mais le
combat d'une réflexion reporter en tout
cas parce que on s'aperçoit bien que les
collectivités ou un mal fou à mettre ça
en place non seulement pour le côté
financier mais aussi vous êtes que c'est
raisonner avant 40000 euros à passer ça
alors aujourd'hui comme je le dis
souvent il ya deux casquettes oreille à
la casquette de l'élu qui te peut que
constater l'échec de cette mise en place
de ce décret et puis il ya le
gestionnaire de la ville avec la tempe
des parents de savoir comment ça va se
passer à la rentrée et donc après une
grande discussion très longue avec
l'inspecteur d'académie et bien nous
avons trouvé un moyen de passages dirais
pour donner un peu de sérénité aux
familles plaisir oasis est ce que j'ai
annoncée cette semaine par le biais
d'une lettre à tous les parents d'élèves
et puis aussi un article dans
l'essentiel qui est le journal de l'île
a expliqué l'accord que vous avez trouvé
parce que effectivement il faut savoir
que le le temps périscolaire dépend du
choix d'un maire par contre le temps
scolaire défini lui par l'état donc en
gros vous êtes obligés d'appliquer la
réforme à la rentrée 2014 est pas le
choix j'appellerai passe à appliquer la
réforme je dirais la grand-place
autoritaire vous n'avez pas le choix du
créneau horaire des horaires d'entrée de
sortie de classe je n'ai pas la
possibilité de mettre au chômage les
enseignants le mercredi matin pour ne
pas le dire pour une panne cité sur les
trois heures qui sont demandés par
ministère de l'éducation nationale sinon
effectivement bien je me mets hors la
loi dans le sens de cette non
l'ouverture mais il est 3h à compenser
sur les temps périscolaires
ça c'est autre chose et ça nous ne les
mettons pas en place
nous mettons en place une autre forme je
dirais d'accompagnement des enfants tout
à fait sécuriser tout à fait
intelligemment mise en place et ce par
exemple et qui est de je dirais d'ouvrir
les écoles à la même heure qu
aujourd'hui de fermer les écoles
normalement devraient se terminer à
16h30 se termineront à 16 heures mais
nous ferons une récréation je dirais un
encadrement des enfants entre 16h et
16h30 pour que les parents qui ont
besoin de venir les chercher à 16h30 et
bien puisse le faire et ensuite nous
prendrons le relais avec les centres de
loisirs et puis bien sûr tout ce qui est
soutien ce ne sera pas une grande
modification de ce qui existe
aujourd'hui sauf le mercredi matin sauf
le mercredi matin qui n'est pas de notre
fait qui est du fait du ministère pour
le reste et bien il y aura un quart
d'heure de plus entre midi pour les
cantines d'ajouter de temps de temps en
accompagnement des enfants et puis
effectivement comme jeu
c'est cette demi heure que j'appellerais
la récré à mon art et création
effectivement jeu de mots plongea comme
j'ai dit vous êtes de l'association des
gilet jaune c'est la source association
qui regroupe des parents d'élèves des
enseignants et vous êtes également ou
même maman de trois enfants vous avez un
enfant moyenne section qui deux enfants
cm1 cm2 donc il y en a déjà deux qui
seront forcément concerné en septembre
2014 par la réforme vous habitez un
petit village on peut le dire
richebourg voilà qu'est ce que qu'est ce
que vous reprochez entre guînes à cette
réforme des temps scolaires
alors moi ce qui m'a mobilisé par
rapport à cette réforme c'est pas le
fait de rajouter une matinée où c'est
vraiment
l'inégalité qui va cette réforme qui
était censé aplanir les inégalités
donner toutes les chances et la même
qualité aux enfants
on observe que sur le territoire est
bien en fonction des du bon vouloir d'un
maire ou des finances d'une commune est
bien le ce qui sera proposé aux familles
et donc aux enfants ne sera pas du tout
la même chose
il y aura donc un plaisir effectivement
le mercredi matin sans travail est bon
ça c'est le le cadre scolaire mais le
cadre extrascolaire finalement va pas
beaucoup être modifié en comparaison la
ville de trappes qui a appliqué dès
septembre 2013 la réforme ou là il ya
beaucoup il ya beaucoup plus d'activités
périscolaires oui enfin là la réforme
dans la ville de trappes s'était
accompagnée de nombreux mouvements de
parents je sais pas si vous aviez suivi
assez compliqué voilà moi je moi ce qui
me dérange c'est vraiment cette
territorialisation de l'école je trouve
que c'est c'est pas bon pour pour les
enfants et ça veut dire que l'enfant qui
va habiter dans cette villa n'aura pas
du tout les mêmes accès aux mêmes choses
que l'enfant qui habitent ailleurs et là
c'est des inégalités financières une
fois de plus la ont par contre on
renforce encore plus on a observé que
bah du coup avec ces temps périscolaire
la fatigue des enfants est accrue en
niant milieu fin de semaine les retours
qu'on a nous c'est que les enfants le
jeudi sont fatigués on déplore que les
enfants handicapés soit complètement
oublié parce que sur l'étang
d'encadrement alors tu es ap aurait créé
à mon autre chose les enfants qui sont
pris en charge par une avs en clis et
ben y'a rien donc ils se retrouvent sur
les bancs et c'est pas voilà on déplore
le fait que pour pouvoir encadrer les
enfants dans de bonnes conditions il
faudrait des gens qui sont un minimum
formé à l'heure actuelle on manque
d'animateurs donc là elle à lisieux par
exemple ils ont besoin là de quarante
cinq animateurs pour dans trois mois ils
ont ils ont fait leur projet et ils en
ont trouvé 15 dans ses 15 y en a sept
qui n'ont aucune formation qui n'ont pas
de baffes acquis qu'ils se sont
peut-être jamais occupé d'enfants et
voilà bertrand mesure alors le pour
présenter la parole des enseignants
globalement sur le département
mais si on prend par exemple l'exemple
de la ville de trappes est ce qu'il ya
eu notamment toutes ces difficultés donc
par l ange a comme sur le recrutement
des animateurs et quel bilan aujourd'hui
on peut tu iras presque un an de la mise
en place à écouter le bilan on peut le
tirer sur trappe mais on peut le tirer
sur les trois grosses communes qui ont
fait cet essai sur le secteur de 5 voilà
que ce soit pas aussi les mureaux et rap
il ya des changements très importants
qui sont intervenus et kiffa qui vont
intervenir la prochaine rentrée
donc ça met en exergue le fait que c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement complexe de
mélanger le temps scolaire et le temps
périscolaire les enseignants ce qu'ils
souhaitent c'est que le temps de l'école
relève de la seule éducation nationale
que l'éducation nationale se donne les
moyens d'assurer un enseignement de
qualité et que cet enseignement de
qualité puisse se faire au travers d'un
certain nombre d'éléments
le premier s'est il nous semble
indispensable de redéfinir les
programmes à fond même de s'intéresser à
la façon dont on va les exécuter la
deuxième chose c'est que la réforme ne
règle pas la nécessité de compenser les
inégalités territoriales ou très à la
marge puisque même le peu de fonds
d'amorçage qui est prévu n'est pas
pérennisés et que l'une des l'un des
éléments caractéristiques de la
difficulté c'est justement les
inégalités territoriales dans le premier
degré donc nous ce que nous
souhaiterions c'est que ces éléments là
soient pris en compte après l'autre
élément qui freinent seulement avoir en
tête c'est que lorsqu'il ya eu la
précédente modification des horaires
scolaires
pas plus les parents que les maires que
les que les enseignants n'avaient été
consultés du jour au lendemain on était
passé de cinq demi journées le matin à
quatre sans aucune concertation d'un
simple trait de plume
là on a l'impression qu'on revient à la
même chose même s'il ya une concertation
qui s'est mise en place
celle qu'on ne prend pas le temps avant
de prendre l'ensemble des paramètres et
d'essayer de voir ce qu'il est
nécessaire de faire pour arriver à ce
qu'on attend là il ya eu une année quand
même entre la mise en place par
certaines communes en septembre et la
mise en place qui va être effective en
septembre 2014 a comme une année mais ça
n'a pas suffi cette année non elle n'a
pas suffi parce que de notre point de
vue à partir du moment où on donne les
clefs de l'école omer qu'ils ont de fait
parce qu'il sait lui qui possède les
locaux ont risqué de se retrouver dans
des situations extrêmement diverses d'un
territoire à l'autre et c'est
effectivement ce qui se produit
d'autre part cette réforme n'a pas été
assez loin dans ce que pouvait être les
différences qui peut y avoir entre une
petite commune rurale on évoquer
richebourg mais des communes en montagne
etc ou des communes qui ont des
spécificités vous évoquiez trappe
c'est difficile à trappes de mettre en
place des choses comme ça et je crois
que la mairie rencontrent de grandes
difficultés pour recruter des animateurs
nombre suffisant pour l'année prochaine
donc elle souhaite que les enseignants
s'engagent mais il est de leur liberté
de leur choix de vie personnelle et
familiale de ne pas forcément être
disponible à l'issue de leur temps de
travail pour pouvoir organiser parce que
c'est ces temps là puisque eux mêmes ont
des enfants dans d'autres communes et
qu'ils vont être amenés à eux aussi à
s'en occuper
donc
tout ça de notre point de vue n'a pas
été assez réfléchi et nous souhaitons
nous que nous aurions souhaité c'est que
la discussion puisse s'engager à partir
d'un cadrage national
assez assez marqué et qui aurait pu se
décliner au travers des expérimentations
dans certaines communes
mais on n'en est pas du tout là dessus
l'expérimentation devient la règle de
base est alors le dernier point c'est
vraiment le mélange du scolaire et du
périscolaire qui apporte toute une série
de désordre j'ajouterai un dernier point
c'est l'illusion qu'il y a derrière à
dire aux parents que cette réforme va
améliorer la situation de l'école avec
madame tout à l'heure nous évoquions la
situation du remplacement sur le
département qui est catastrophique et la
première des obligations à notre sens de
l'éducation d'intérêt c'est de faire en
sorte qu'ils aient un mètre de vente
chaque classe chaque jour et ça n'a
absolument pas été cas cette année on
s'est retrouvé dans une situation que
nous avions connu il ya deux ans il est
peu probable que les choses s'améliorent
l'année prochaine puisque le métier de
winne ans de moins en moins attractif
les concours ne remplissent plus c'est à
dire que on a énormément de jeunes
comment dirais-je master qui ne veulent
plus faire ce métier donc on reste avec
les choses à régler avant de passer à la
réforme des rites tout à fait vrai
j'aurais quand même pas qu'on parle
aussi parce qu'on a beaucoup parlé de
finances mais ce serait aussi bien de
parler du bien-être de l'enfant je
voudrais vous faire réagir sur une
citation divan du professeur yvon
tweetie les chronobiologistes de
l'académie de médecine et lui il affirme
que le retour à la semaine des quatre
jours et demi va d'une part permettre
d'apporter plus de souplesse dans le
temps nécessaire à l'enfant pour
assimiler tous qu'il tout ce qui est
requis doit être assimilée et puis
d'autre part ça va diminuer les effets
de désynchronisation de l'enfant les
lundis et les mardis parce que du coup
ça lui fera une semaine une semaine
complète alors vous en pensez quoi
parce qu'effectivement il est dit que
les enfants les enfants sont quand même
ont plus de facilité à se concentrer
le matin par exemple que l'après-midi
oui elle en disque ou en étalant le
temps scolaire et enfin moi je me moi
personnellement après là je parle plus
au nom de tous les gilet jaune mais moi
personnellement je remets pas en cause
la possibilité de remettre une matinée
en plus ou par contre là dans la réforme
telle qu'elle est ficelé par exemple il
ya énormément de communes pour échapper
fond du bidouillage et donc libère tous
le vendredi après midi donc là on se
retrouve avec une coupure de deux jours
et demi je suis pas très sûr que ce soit
vraiment bénéfique
enfin je ne pense pas qu'on y gagne
c'est à dire que finalement ou dit quoi
là la réforme elle est cadrée mais n'est
peut-être pas encore assez cadré jeudi
à la base c'était pour un mieux-être un
mieux apprentissage de l'enfant là je
reçois je rejoins tout à fait monsieur
bien besoin car je suis navré oui c'est
qu'il faut les programmes ne sont donc
entièrement à revoir les enseignants il
faut il faut absolument revaloriser
cette profession on manque on manque de
remplaçants les classes sont surchargées
alors parrish bourg on a justement
désavantage les écoles voilà on a des
petites la c1 légère et c'est l'essai
très agréable pour les enseignants de
travailler dans ces conditions de
l'encadrement des enfants est bien
meilleur et l'apprentissage se fait bien
mieux et là je suis pas sûr que ce soit
une histoire de demi journées en plus ou
en moins au niveau des enseignants de
plaisir qu'est ce qui vous auront nous
ont remonté ce moment niveau de cette
réforme des rythmes scolaires c'était
plutôt contre où ils ont tous atteint on
dit plutôt pour l'intérêt de l'enfant
c'est intéressant d'étaler sa sur cinq
jours comme nous avons eu le temps de
faire une concertation pendant plus d'un
an et demi et beaucoup échangé avec eux
il était très circonspect par rapport à
7 ce décret sur l'intérêt de l'enfant
ça a été assez clair alors je peux pas
parler pour l'ensemble et dire
qu'effectivement ils étaient tous contre
je pourrais en décevoir certains d'avoir
ces propos là mais en tout cas c'est
vrai qu'il y avait une grosse
interrogation mais pour rejoindre ce que
vous disiez tous les deux je ne peux
qu'abonder dans tout ce que j'entends il
ya un mélange des genres effectivement
comme disait monsieur l'éducation c'est
l'éducation et puis tout ce qui est en
périscolaire c'est autre chose hélas il
ya un mélange des gens on nous met une
responsabilité nous mère qui est une
responsabilité que je considère un peu
déplacé en tout cas certes il faudra
certainement la pique et on n'aura pas
le choix mais il est important
aujourd'hui d'avoir toujours comme comme
base de réflexion
l'intérêt de l'enfant je suis pas du
tout convaincu aujourd'hui qu'on ait
trouvé la bonne méthode et que si je
demandais précédemment dans d'autres
entretiens à monsieur armand de bien
vouloir prendre le degré nationale oui
député des yvelines je précise tout à
fait voisin de plaisir en tout cas dire
que ce serait bien qu'ils viennent
effectivement se rapprocher des
collectivités on avait déjà demandé pour
faire des simulations
effectivement les communes ne traite pas
les affaires de la même façon une petite
commune une moyenne une grande n'ont pas
du tout les mêmes possibilités
et même si nous plaisir donnant
l'impression d'avoir des possibilités
des capacités tout est proportionnel
quand vous avez une école et vous en
avez 30 comme nous forcément les coûts
sont proportionnelles et on se retrouve
devant des confrontations difficile et
puis c'est vrai je trouve que on est en
train de encore une fois donner aux
collectivités des responsabilités qui ne
sont pas les nôtres
et à partir de là il ya vraiment une
question de fond à se poser sur cette
façon de se décharger de l'état sur les
collectivités
on en a peut-être même pas les
compétences voudrais revenir sur le
problème du financement puisque vous
avez dans la vie de le plaisir ça
représente 475 euros
ça représente 400 mille euros pour le
ne mord pas le maire divers droite de
versailles françois de mazières
ok quand même connu pour être un homme
plutôt consensuel a lancé une pétition
en ligne sur le site internet de la
commune parce qu'en fait il explique ça
nous coûterait deux points d'impôt la
mise en place de cette réforme
comment vous expliquez cette cette
fronde l'impression d'une fronde un peu
bas de droite contre un contre un contre
un et lui et contre un ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui est lui
notamment à trappes qui est social
socialiste parce que c'est une fronde
d'abord politique je vais vous dire que
dit benoît hamon est dit à jean françois
copé
calmez vos troupes oui l'agent fascinant
car c'est normal qu'il le dise mais en
tout cas ce que moi je peux vous dire
très très très sincèrement et je les ai
évoqué plusieurs fois si tu étais un
décret de droiture et fait exactement la
même chose
c'est à dire que là je suis pas du tout
en train de parler politique droite
gauche c'est pas du tout un refus
s'avère qu'il ya que des communes de
droite qui protestent non je crois ne
l'entendît challenge est là oui on a
beaucoup on a des instituteurs aussi
pour répondre à la question qui déposait
tout à l'heure dans les gîtes dont ceux
des malades et des deux états et pas
vraiment politique il est vraiment
d'organes d'organisation et de questions
financières
quand le ministre nous avons dit qu'en
gros les communes toucheront 50 euros
par enfant donc ça fait quand même de
l'argent vous avez ri moyer 3000 élèves
dans votre travail vous voilà sur la
ville de plaisir ça fait quand même un
oui c'est une somme est-ce que nous nous
notre installation de rythme sera mise
en place de façon définitive alors
est-ce que cet accompagnement va être
définitif est ce qu'il va être
concomitant à tout cela je pense que
c'est un effet d'annoncé pour une année
voire deux mais il ya plus alors du coup
du coup c'est 50 euros vous allez en
faire quoi
vous allez encore faut-il leur en
demander encore faut-il les demandes et
donc
on fera le nécessaire puisque de toute
façon on devait engager 25 personnes
pour les rythmes scolaires dans
l'ancienne méthode que l'on voulait
faire
aujourd'hui il faut quand même que nous
engagions ce quinze personnes dont
quinze personnes à temps complet c'est
quand même un coup je suis plus à 700000
euros mais je vais être certainement
autour des 350 400 mille euros dont
c'est toujours ça de pris
on va dire mais mais si vous laissez
c'est pas très agréable de porter ce
débat qui est un débat de fond sociétal
d'éducation et de collectivités de
responsabilité sur une question d'argent
parce que c'est vraiment pas ses sources
que vous moi vous allez met en avant si
l'hadopi donne elle aussi bien la balle
oui parce que parce que les mères ont
d'abord remonté en disant ça va nous
coûter cher on va pas pouvoir la mettre
en place oui parce qu'on nous demande en
permanence de ne pas augmenter les
impôts chose que l'on fait depuis de
nombreuses années et puis d'un autre
côté vous le savez nous avons des pères
de dotation qui sont très importantes
donc à un moment donné il faut aussi
être gestionnaire on peut pas être moi
je me sens pas être la fée clochette qui
a les possibilités de tout résoudre
comme ça donc on a ce côté gestionnaires
de la ville sérénité de la ville et puis
bon sens que moi je revendique tout le
temps donc c'est vraiment pas une
histoire politique même si monsieur
hamon arrête pas de dire que la ville de
plaisir c'est un épiphénomène et que de
toute façon je serai obligé de
l'appliquer ajouté c'est le débat c'est
l'intérêt de l'enfant et l'intérêt de
l'enfant n'est pas politique
c'est un enfant il est pas de droite de
gauche ce qui est bon pour lui c'est ça
n'a rien à voir avec un avec la
politique
si vous permettez ajouter quelque chose
la précédente réforme des rythmes
scolaires avaient été faites dans un
seul objectif qui était celui de
diminuer le nombre d'enseignants puisque
les trois heures qui a été supprimée
avait servi entre autres à financer
entre guillemets toute une série de
dispositifs qui offrait déjà moins de
temps de classe aux élèves quel qu'il
soit y compris ceux qui étaient les plus
en difficulté et donc là déjà en été
dans cette dans cette dimension
financière il faut savoir que la france
dans tous les classements internationaux
et en ce qui concerne l'école primaire
maternelle élémentaire se place très mal
en terme
dépense par élève et que l'école un coot
pour nous ce coût doit être assuré par
la collectivité nationale parce que
c'est la seule façon d'assurer les
compensations territoriales dont on
parlait tout à l'heure et que ce coup tu
dois ne doit pas être perçu comme étant
quelque chose de de jeu dira à fonds
perdus or force est de constater que
depuis des années le budget de
l'éducation nationale a diminué et que
malgré les annonces de deux postes qui
vont être donnée à l'éducation nationale
on ne fera que compensé en très petite
partie enfin pape totalité les
suppressions qui a vu ces dernières
années dans un contexte d'augmentation
démographique
donc voilà on est dans cette situation
là et le fond du problème c'est que déjà
il faut faire fonctionner l'école de
façon satisfaisante et on en est très
loin on en est très loin et pour nous si
le fait de revenir à cinq matinées pour
un grand nombre de collègues c'était
quelque chose de positif parce que lille
avait il savait ce que ça pouvait
apporter leur dès samedi matin
le fait d'avoir cinq demi journées le
matin c'est quelque chose de positif
pour autant ça ne suffit pas et ça ne
suffira pas à régler les différends ça
c'est sûr que ce n'est certainement pas
une demi journée qui va permettre de
tout régler qu'est ce que vous allez
faire vos après le 6 juin donc le 6 juin
vous ne remettrait pas votre dossier à
l'inspection académique le site un
dossier
l'inspecteur académique a reçu notre
courrier d'adaptation de ce que je viens
d'évoquer
sur ces fameux trois heures que nous
avons réparti de façon non satisfaisante
à mon goût donc je pense que
l'inspecteur d'académie va prendre acte
et il va considérer que nous avons mis
en place et rythmes scolaires
j'imagine que ça va se passer comme ça
donc qu'en septembre sera mis en place
et bien ce que je vous ai évoqué la
safer a mis en place votre formule avec
ma formule de la récré amant et puis
surtout avec une sérénité attendue par
les parents mais je peux vous dire que
je continuerai vraiment
2 je dirais d'essayer de faire réfléchir
le gouvernement surtout ce que viennent
d'évoquer ces personnes qui sont des
choses fondamentales et que l'on doit
absolument vous remettre en réflexion je
dis pas en abandon mais en réflexion
vous avez rendez vous avec le revoir
certainement s'il ya un comité
départemental café on sait dès lors il
monta d'éducation il va se tenir vers le
20 juin après pour statuer
mais je suivais prévu vous revoyez on va
se revoir avec les autres communes ya
pas qu il les adore et bien sûr non non
non mais c'est important de se revoir
puisque je pense que il est important
d'avoir un consensus à un moment donné
comme je vous disais pour le respect de
la sérénité des familles parce qu'il
l'attendait aussi pour les enseignants
qui le mercredi matin vont bien devoir
rentrer quelque part pour assumer les
cours mais je crois qu'en tant que
politique avec cette casquette de
réflexion je dirais de solutions à
trouver
je crois qu'il faut il faut continuer il
faut y aller je peux dire on est
plusieurs à penser que la réforme n'est
pas en place elle n'est pas prête
elle apporte beaucoup de souffrances à
tout le monde je pense que plus les
années vont passer et plus on se rendra
compte que au niveau des enfants on n'a
pas trouvé la bonne solution dont nous
fassent confiance vont continuer tous
les deux aussi être engagée si vous
permettez le constat qui est fait sur
huit communes dans les yvelines qui va
être fait très certainement sur le 92
parce que dans le 92
aucune commune de l'affairé dernière
c'est on a ajouté un constate des
organisations est actuellement l'école a
besoin d'autre chose que d'être
désorganisées certainement elle a besoin
au contraire de se reconstruire de ceux
de repartir sur des programmes solide
pérenne parce que on a changé trois fois
de deux programmes en l'espace de 5 6
ans donc voilà elle a besoin de ça elle
n'a pas besoin de cette désorganisation
or elle rime et demandé un report nous
ce qu'on demande c'est que le décret
soit réécrit c'est que l'on suspende les
choses et qu'on reprenne les choses au
haut à la base idem pour la sociologie
et jean vêtements complètement que le
décrit soit abrogée con
qu'on arrête de faire du bidouillage on
parle d'enfants quand même on parle
c'est nos enfants c'est pas et qu'on
qu'on se laisse le temps voilà de
travailler en concertation avec bapt est
maintenant justement un petit peu plus
de de deux voix la nouvelle proposition
de benoît n'en ont pas d'allègements
d'assoupissement pas suffit à vous
convaincre
écouter les propositions ce qui est
remarquable dans cette histoire là c'est
que le décret qui était pris au mois de
janvier les assouplissements de noix
mots non n'englobe même pas les quelques
expériences qu'il existe ici ou là et
qui déjà était à quatre jours et demi
c'est à dire que ceux qui avaient déjà
travaillé à ces éléments là et qu'il
avait mis en place ne rentre même pas
dans le cadre du décret
donc il ya un moment où il faut se poser
la question la housse et pérenne ou ça
donne satisfaction
on va aller modifier quelque chose et là
où ça il ya quand même des questions à
se poser
oui ça m'a vraiment dire que ce serait
dommage que les bidouillages dont dix
par les madame mais que je respecte le
mot que l'on met en place dans certaines
communes parce qu'on n'a pas le choix on
est obligé vraiment je trouve que c'est
une prise en otage quelques pas et bien
ça soit pas considéré par le
gouvernement comme une application du
décret parce que ça ne l'est pas
aujourd'hui nous mettons en place
quelque chose pour donner rien de la
version tout cas mon droit d'être venu
sur la distance continue et je rappelle
donc les communes ont jusqu'au 6 juin
pour rendre leur copie au conseil
départemental d'éducation serait une
réunira pardon vers le 20 juin pour
statuer mais selon toute vraisemblance
la réforme des rythmes scolaires devrait
donc s'appliquer à la rentrée 2014 bonne
soirée à vous